[Música]
y aquí en France 24 es momento de hablar
de economía y por ello me acompañan el
estudio mi compañero Luis Méndez Luis
bienvenido vamos a iniciar hablando del
acuerdo firmado este viernes entre China
y Argentina así es Es un acuerdo de
cooperación que busca profundizar lazos
en materia económica y comercial de
acuerdo con medios chinos y argentinos
el plan es profundizar la cooperación en
Campos como la infraestructura la
energía la economía y el comercio este
es una implementación del memorando de
entendimiento que ambos países firmaron
en el año 2022 adicionalmente Argentina
consiguió una renovación de el Swap un
acuerdo de intercambio Financiero en el
que una de las partes Se compromete a
pagar con determinada periodicidad una
serie de flujos monetarios de acuerdo
con el medio ámbito financiero de
Argentina este será por tres años más y
por 19.000 millones de dólares o 130 mil
millones de yuanes para uso de libre
disponibilidad
que de acuerdo con el gobierno actuales
servirán para el desarrollo sin importar
quién esté gobernando el país vamos a
hablar ahora del nuevo presidente del
Banco Mundial Así es se trata del
estadounidense de ascendencia India Jay
manga ex director ejecutivo de la
empresa más cerca de quien ASUME el
organismo con sede en Washington bajo la
premisa de convertir su accionar en una
labor transformadora en un tweet del
propio banco se le dio la bienvenida e
invitó a muchos a acompañarlo en su
objetivo de crear un mundo libre de
pobreza en un planeta habitable para
banca el cambio climático es primordial
y de acuerdo con la revista Force además
de trabajar para disminuir su impacto el
nuevo presidente estimo un alivio de
deuda para aquellos países que se vean
afectados por desastres naturales en su
primer día de trabajo pidió a sus más de
16.000 empleados duplicar esfuerzos por
otro lado señaló que el banco debe
volverse más eficiente disminuyendo los
tiempos para la aprobación de proyectos
que en la actualidad puede demorar hasta
tres años también su inicio en el banco
mundial se presenta un día después de
sostener una reunión con Janeth la
secretaria del tesoro de Estados Unidos
en la cual entre otras cosas tienen le
instó aprovechar más el balance del
banco y a movilizar el capital privado
este fue electo para un periodo de 5
años tras ser nominado por el presidente
Joe biden para este cargo y así
sustituye a tebi Malpaso bueno pasamos a
Francia hay una calificadora de riesgo
que ha puesto mucha atención al
desarrollo de la actividad en el país
estamos hablando de la calificadora
estándar and purse que puso bajo la lupa
al país europeo en parte por la
preocupación en el aumento de deudas
nacional dentro de esa nación recordemos
que el país avanza hacia un plan de
reforma pensional que ha generado
inconformidad en gran parte de la
población en este sentido la agencia
calificadora de riesgo optó por dejar al
país en el nivel doble a Qué significa
una nación sólida financieramente pero
hizo la advertencia que la perspectiva
sigue siendo negativa para la agencia
mantener el nivel de clasificación se
debe a la estrategia revisada de
consolidación presupuestaria del
gobierno francés Luis cambiamos de
región nos vamos a México ayer fueron
presentados los datos de empleo del mes
de abril Lamentablemente mientras su
socio comercial como lo es Estados
Unidos avanzó con una creación de 339
mil puestos de empleo la nación vecina
retrocedió en otras palabras el
Instituto Nacional de estadística y
geografía Indicó que el desempleo se
incrementó cuatro décimas al pasar de un
2,4 en el mes de marzo a un 2,8 en el
mes de abril números redondos significa
una reducción de 112 mil puestos de
empleo siendo este el dato más elevado
desde diciembre del año pasado esto En
parte por un aumento de la población
económicamente activa que según el Inegi
se ubica en la 152.000 o 289 personas
vamos con Los indicadores económicos de
la jornada se mezclaron dos cosas
Valentina anoche el acuerdo del techo de
la deuda para ampliarlo y también en los
resultados de empleo de Estados Unidos
para un cierre positivo de los
principales mercados en Wall Street a lo
largo de la jornada y sobre todo para
este día viernes una situación que
también se sintió en los mercados
europeos y asiáticos donde los
principales mercados cerraron con
números positivos en parte a este
acuerdo alcanzado por Estados Unidos
para el techo de la deuda que evita
impagos en cuanto a algunas deudas del
mercado japonés también cerró con
números positivos en América Latina la
situación de Wall Street permitió
también un cierre positivo para los
principales
mercados destacando el caso de Colombia
y que Argentina en esta actualidad como
los que representaron crecimiento
positivo y cerramos con la cifra del día
tiene que ver en este caso con los 53,1
kilogramos cápita que sería el estimado
de consumo de carne a lo largo del 2023
de acuerdo con algunos organismos que
citan la agencia de noticias routers
Aunque este dato refleja un crecimiento
Comparado con años recientes anteriores
todavía se encuentra lejos de los 60 o
70 kilogramos de décadas atrás también
hay que tomar en cuenta que estamos
hablando de la nación de Argentina que
presenta como el segundo dato más alto
en la inflación en cuanto alimentos
después a usted muchas gracias por esta
ampliación económica aquí en directo
América lo invito a que continúe con
nosotros que ya vamos con nuestra
sección de deportes